one other critical component for women
in terms of confidence is authenticity
and we found after a lot of interviews
and especially some insightful guidance
from Christine Lagarde who's the the
first female head of the IMF and just a
wonderful confidence role model that
confidence will not always look the same
way in women as it does in men it won't
always manifest itself the same way so
we all think of confidence in this kind
of Mad Men style bravado speaking up
first I'm going to do this I'll handle
that that's not necessarily that may
just be male behavior that might not be
the way confidence will look in a
confident woman and an understanding
that there has to be an authenticity to
our confidence I think is very important
and very powerful because again in all
of the data about diversity and why
diversity works in the workplace and why
it helps the bottom line of companies
it's because it's a diversity of style
and management style and again it's you
know a diversity of confidence is also
something that I think is is very
powerful for companies